Speaker 1: So there's growing pressure, so-called
from Republicans for Joe Biden to be screened
for dementia like Donald Trump was, and this
all relates to the Montreal cognitive assessment
or the Moka, as it's called, which Donald
Trump, you might remember, took during his
time in the White House.
And Trump hasn't stopped bragging about the
results ever since.
Even at one point, remember telling reporters
like Chris Wallace, accusing them during an
interview, you couldn't do as well as me on
those tests.
And Trump keeps calling it a cognitive test.
Trump brags about his great score and how
it proves something, I guess, about his intelligence.
The reality is, I've told you before, is that
this test is meant to screen out serious dementia,
pretty serious advanced dementia, sometimes
used to evaluate patients after strokes to
see what their cognitive functioning is.
It's not really something to brag about.
It's just a very crude and basic screening
tool to find out is something really wrong
here where someone has forgotten what a camel
looks like.
Now, you might be wondering why is this an
issue now?
Again, this is present now because Trump won't
stop talking about it.
And Dr. Ronnie Jackson, Trump's former White
House doctor, who's now a congressman, is
saying that Joe Biden should take the test.
Don Jr. is saying Joe Biden should take the
test.
Donald Trump has now started saying that Joe
Biden should take the test.
But in so doing, Trump just can't control
himself.
He can't stop bragging about the test.
Trump went down to the US Mexico border with
Republican Governor of Texas Greg Abbott.
And they had like a little press event.
And somehow Trump gets on the topic of his
dementia test and how Biden should take the
test.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: But he did a test.
Did I it?
I taste it.
And I'd like to see Biden.
He said he won't.
He said he'll get the first thirty five questions
and the first two or three are pretty easy.
The animals.
This is a lion, a giraffe, when it gets to
around 20, is going to have a little hard
time.
I think he's going to have a hard time with
the first few, actually.
But so we really have something.
Speaker 1: Now, Trump is just wrong about
basically everything.
As usual.
There aren't 35 questions.
There are 30 points.
There's really like 19 or 23 questions, depending
on how you count them.
So, like, even Trump's recollection of what
the test is, is wrong, but he keeps insisting
with it.
But somehow Trump is obsessed with the test.
Here he is talking to Sean Hannity, also at
the border part of his Mexico border propaganda
tour that he did last week during our vacation.
Listen to Trump and Sean Hannity helping to
push this nonsense about the difficulty of
the test
Speaker 2: in trouble with his government.
We wasted I think I can say that.
I think we get what you didn't get one question
wrong.
Did 30 out of 30.
Wow.
Speaker 1: I have to tell you, the crowd cheering
is just something else.
I mean, they're cheering for what is a normal
state.
They're cheering for not suffering from serious
dementia.
These are people who would clap for anything.
Consider what it is they're clapping for.
It's pathetic.
The president passed the test meant to screen
for serious cognitive impairment.
Yeah, what a manly guy.
Our leader.
Here's the rest of the clip.
And Trump again saying the test is just much
tougher than the media will tell you.
And they did
Speaker 2: get a little more difficult after
you got by 15, I would say.
But I heard the first three questions are,
is it a joke or an elephant?
Right.
Well, you know, that's what the effect is
as they take the first two or three questions
and they put that and they put them in.
But let me tell you, they would not get those
last 15, right?
Certainly not the last 10 that I can tell
you.
But anyway,
Speaker 1: so again, Dr. Ronnie Jackson, Trump's
former doctor, now just a bomb throwing congressman,
also pushing this and saying that something
is going on.
Biden needs a test.
And just to remind you about the test, by
the way, this really is an easy test.
We've got it up on the screen.
I mean, it's, you know, stuff like draw a
clock that shows that it's 11 10, identify
a lion, a rhino and a camel.
Remember, repeat back to me the words face
velvet church.
Daisy read, read a list of digits and then
you count them back, like the tester would
say to one eight, five four.
And you have to say two one eight five four
or repeat the numbers backwards, seven, four
two.
And you say to four seven, subtract by seven
out loud, you know, like 193.
Eighty six, seventy nine.
This is the test.
When Trump says there are tougher questions,
you know, there's one called abstraction,
which is like what are the similarities between
train and bicycle to which you would say,
oh, sir, those are methods of transportation
or, you know, things Republicans oppose, depending
on your perspective, a watch and a ruler.
Well, both of those help you measure different
things.
The watch measures time and the ruler measures
like this is what this is the difficult tests
that Trump is talking about.
So it's all pathetic.
It seems to be another distraction narrative,
quite frankly.
And it is bizarre that Donald Trump is still
obsessed
with it.